[Music]
hello and welcome back to
chessopenings.com McCarroll con of
course over the past few weeks I've gone
over all of the lines of the caro-kann
just to briefly show you once again
CARICOM of course starts after E for c6
and d4 is the main variation so d4 of
course followed by d5 and then we looked
at the advanced variation we looked at
the exchange variations we looked at the
classical variations and we dove pretty
deep into all of those but today I
wanted to kind of round out the
repertoire against 1.e4 by introducing
some of the side lines that white can
play of course these include various
lines such as - d3 which kind of goes
into the suit or not the suit of pan off
the suit up and off is also on we'll be
taking a look at but after 2 D 3 white
goes into the Kings Indian attack type
of structures of course the Kings Indian
attack like the Kings Indian defense for
black except it is an opening for white
aha well Mike adjustment I'm just gonna
take a jacket off
okay so d3 entering the Kings Indian
attack type of structures of kings in
the attack like the Kings Indian defense
except with the white pieces so expect
wait to see to play common moves like
this fianchetto bring this Knight out to
d2 and go for stuff like f4 in in the
mirror took too late future and so I
wanted to introduce a line for black
against this that still follows a lot of
the caro-kann ideas so of course I'm
going to recommend you start with d5 so
the whole point of the caro-kann you
support the center in order to push this
move d5 so that's what we do here now by
far the most common response for white
is
Knight d2 and the reason is white likes
to block off this file to avoid any
Queen traits now here if white plays the
move Knight f3 first you do have this
option to take on e4 and take on d1
you're by no means obligated to play
like this you can still just go for your
normal stuff with g6 and against 92 that
is what I'm going to recommend I'm going
to recommend to move g6 Knight of three
would stop black's most common move
which is e 5 but Knight f3 of course
does nothing to stop this move g6 so our
repertoire is kind of safe against this
move order trickery
so g6 now the most common move for white
is Knight f3 and this is what we kind of
call a system for white so white has a
few different move orders he can choose
from but in the end he's going to play
more or less the same setup so he's kind
of just playing a system no matter what
black's doing white is going to kind of
play these moves in some order and so
because of that black also has some
freedom to pick what he wants to do and
how he wants to do it so this is just
one of the setups that I'm recommending
so g6 Bishop g7 the natural follow up
white will Fein keto at some point and
I'm gonna recommend black goes for this
nice move e5 so very common in chess
openings one player will try to seize
the center and the other player will try
to play against the center trying to
attack the center from the wings trying
to attack perhaps an overextended center
but the fact is controlling the center
is still going to be important so when
your opponent doesn't see central
squares like e5 it's generally good to
take them even if you're a little bit
concerned that it might come under fire
at a later date so E 5 definitely going
to be the idea here for black now Bishop
g2 is logical for white and I recommend
the move Knight East 7 just to not
interfere with this Bishop you need this
bishop to kind of support 'if i know
what's gonna go ahead and castle like I
said White's playing a system he's just
almost always going to play these moves
in some order and I'm gonna recommend
that black castles as well and this is
where we kind of arrive at the first big
branch
of the Kings Indian attack for white
white really does have a few different
options he can try here and I'm curious
if the chat room at home already knows
some of these plans so see if you know
some of the common plans for white here
try and come up with at home I'm gonna
pull up the chat on my phone here which
I have failed to do because I was
running against the clock here we go
and I've got you guys now hello hello to
everyone
I've disappointed Dennis I promised I
would go over his glorious win against
Jonathan in the Dennis Danish but I did
not unfortunately end up preparing
Dennis is deadly Danish perhaps another
week so Sarah says f4 and this is in
fact one of the common ideas for white
you know this is the counterpart to the
Kings Indian defense of course in the
Kings Indian defense playing for f5 is
the main idea for black and similarly
white can do such things here but the
move order is is rather important it's
pretty rare that you see the white
player go for something like ninety one
here this has actually never been played
just trying to do this directly and
there's a few reasons for it one I
imagine the move f5 might actually be
strong for black
the reason being White's just a little
bit too slow with this configuration of
the pieces to kind of play like this
black is also fincad owed it moves like
f5 really challenged the white center
and white is just kind of playing down
tempi the other reason for that is
perhaps it's a little bit more common to
go for those types of plans directly if
the move order Knight c3 292 has been
played which in this case due to our
opening choice this Knight almost always
ends up on the d 2 square so 91 an f4
directly doesn't quite make so much
sense in fact it makes even less sense
because black is not committed to
putting this pawn on the d4 square so f4
while it looks a convenient it might
actually if black just does nothing be
convenient for black to take this pawn
and just open up this bishop on the nice
long diagonal we don't make any
weaknesses in our center just yet so f4
isn't going to be the idea just yet much
more common I will say is things such as
the move rook e1 in the move c3 these
are both really common ways for white to
play so the reason rook e1 sometimes
gets played is it does ask black some
pretty awkward questions here namely it
makes a threat of a takes d5 when in
fact this pawn is going to be attacked
twice
so now white or black has to to make
some decisions it is possible to play a
move like 97 and just support the center
even further but you're starting to get
in your own pieces way a little bit and
white can start doing things like like
b4 trying to gain a little bit of space
on on this Queen side so rather I like
just playing the move d4 this is kind of
the whites goal with the move rook e1 to
induce d4 to try and get black to over
commit to this central idea but
controlling center space definitely has
its benefits as opposed to its downsides
now d4 of course gives up a square that
square is on c4 and so the most common
move here for white is Knight c4 when
you can go into some complicated lines
with b5 when night C takes e5 is not so
good due to this move f6 trapping the
night and then the knight likely will
retreat and black is going to start
playing on the Queen side so the move I
wanted to look at is actually the main
move a4 I think this is a better move
for white because it prepares night
seafloor and doesn't allow this move b5
to come quite so quickly ok so a 4 in
the move I'm gonna recommend for black
is actually this move
c5 so it's starting to look just like a
normal Kings Indian defense except of
course the colors are reversed
and so the plans are gonna largely be
the same now the black has fully
committed to the center here white is
likely going to switch back to common
plans like f4 and in the meantime black
is going to try to expand on this Queen
side in order to make his extra space
count and so you can kind of fall back
on these plans if you're familiar at all
with the position with the colors
reversed it's gonna be very useful to
you here because you really are just
playing the same type of position so of
course this means black's plans in these
positions all kind of revolve around
this Queen side the c-4 square is going
to be really really crucial here so
common move for white is Knight c4 and
you can respond to this with Knight bc6
simply guarding this 'if I've pawned
guarding the e5 pawn as I said and then
from here there are a couple options I
like the move rook f1 I think this is
the most instructive so white plays rook
e1 and only then drops it back to f1
seems a little counterintuitive but as I
said the point of rook e1 was to
threaten a takes D and force blacks hand
into playing d4 now that that purpose is
fulfilled it's gonna step back to f1 and
start aiming for f4 f5 now there are a
variety of ways you can really play here
you can start going for things like b6
a6 and b5 although this can be a little
bit slow and so the plan I like best is
the plan played in the game you go for
Bishop e6 and wait for the correct
opportunity to actually snap off this
Knight on c4 and once this Knight
disappears from the board you're free to
kind of break up in the center and start
creating some openings on this side of
the board so instead of Bishop e6
directly you might be running into
Knight g5 and you're not quite ready to
take on c4 so the move played in the
game is h6 simply guarding this g5
square
preparing Bishop e6 and waiting for the
right moment to actually snap off this
Knight so 91 was played in the game and
now Bishop e6 makes a lot of sense and
white continues with at 4 so how do you
want to respond to f4 with black here
there's actually a variety of options
you can go for of course you can take it
you can also ignore it and play
something else or you can go for a move
like f5 so your options are taking this
playing f5 to try and stop these pushes
from white or just do something else in
entirely for example you could capture
here to play move like a six and move
like b6 and move like Earth b8 do any of
those things so so what is the the
YouTube chat at home think about this
position what do you think
what do you think
I'm just waiting for the chat to catch
up me on this one f4 is White's big
break and we have to find a way to
respond so loo trim the goalie says the
move f5 directly okay and someone else
says the move Queen to d7 so these are
both pretty reasonable moves a lot of
people now saying f5 to people want to
capture on f4 and one person wants to
play the move f6 so we're kind of split
here and the fact is there's actually a
few reasonable moves here the move plate
in the game is the response that I
actually quite liked for black and that
is actually to take on f4 now white more
or less I guess you don't have to
recapture what the pawn book but white
does in the game the point being you
just want to keep the threats of playing
f5 alive now as for the other options
for black let's just take a quick look
here if you play the move f5 I think
it's just a little bit too much in fact
this is probably helping white open
things up favorably for him of course
black looking to open things on the
Queen side white actually looking to
open things on the Kings side in in the
center so for example white could even
consider opening everything up here and
then it just becomes kind of a fight on
the Kings side white of course could
also consider it just opening up this
nice diagonal for the bishop let me move
like Queen e2 and increasing the
pressure on on the center and if now we
play F take C you takes F or well
there's a nasty nasty threat on e6 so f5
is probably my least favorite of the
options it just allows white to kind of
open up this Bishop a little bit and
we've already created some some tender
spots in our camp with pushing these
pawns the move f6 is actually really
interesting try and I don't think this
is a bad move at all although it does
slightly kind of allow white to continue
with the plan it was like f5 are still
always going to be a threat you know you
kind of just have to keep your eyes open
for moves like f5 here for example even
immediately you could consider it with
some sacrifices coming on the board and
moves like Queen Age 5
just starting to create some threats
along these open files now but f6
definitely worth considering just to
support this e5 pawn even more but as I
said well first of all you could you
could ignore it but then the move f5
really does start to get pretty powerful
here started start to get pretty
powerful if you take take and take well
then the move Knight takes c6 and you're
already losing a piece so got to be
careful of that five so ignoring it
really the only wrong response f5 I
think just a little bit too weakening
here f6 definitely really interesting
option but I like the movie takes f4 and
after G takes f 4 then the other move
suggested comes into play Queen d7 and
the idea is you just keep a firm grip on
the f5 square but black actually has a
subtler intention with the move Queen d7
so after Knight f3 try and find blacks
next move and come up with with a reason
why you know there is a definite plan
behind black's next move and i may have
already talked to you a little bit about
what that plan might be just a little
bit about what that plan might be
I think it just to be a little bit too
early for a bishop takes c4 plug it we
can look at it again
so someone suggests the move Bishop h3
it's not really the the point of blacks
play here we we're not super interested
in trading off these bishops this Bishop
is not actually White's best piece here
on g2 and this Bishop is doing a lot for
us right now it's doing a lot key
defender okay so we're not really
looking to attack white on the Kings
side in this type of position the Kings
side is where White has more space for
the moment see like white kind of has
control over over this side of the board
here meanwhile we only have this much
space for our pieces you know we can put
the pieces out in front of the pawns but
it's not ideal for for attacking so you
don't really want to go after whites
King on the side where you have West
space here it just doesn't make quite
enough sense
white wants to play night h4 maybe that
definitely could be the case Bishop g4
buy black maybe so I don't like these
moves on on the Kings side I don't think
we need to over commit our pieces to the
Kings side here we need an active plan
for black so someone suggested a6 with
the idea of b5 and this is a pretty
pretty standard plan in King's Indian
structures but the move a5 is really
going to be a little bit of a cold
shower for the black player here now
you're never gonna get b5 through white
is always going to take on passant and
you're not really achieving control of
c4 which is kind of the goal with a 6 so
a6 doesn't quite work and I think b6
with the idea of a 6 + b5 it's just it's
a little bit slow it's a little bit slow
here so the move played in the game no
one suggested it's actually the move
rook a d8 you know of course what's the
point of rook 88 well the point is after
White's next move in the game it was
Queen e1 black wants to take on c4 and
push through to d3 he wants to open up
this diagonal for the bishop open up
this file force pieces and open up the
d4 square for the knight as well this is
how black is looking to get activity in
this position and in fact this is what
was played in the game now if white
takes a slightly slower approach and
plays a move like b3 after a da black
actually has quite a number of options
here you can even still consider it
capturing this night when after B takes
e4 you can start to go for things like
these six now and just think about
cementing a knight on the Queen side
giving white some problems and slowly
going for the plan of a six and B five
the play on the the King side is still
going to be pretty immediate but with a
knight on b4 especially you do have some
threats over here but even better than
this I think is playing the move f5 this
move which I told you guys not to play
moments ago so what has changed
why is f5 better here well the reason is
simply we've included this move he takes
F 4 and G
takes f4 so with this inclusion white is
going to be left with a very awkward
pawn on f4 square that really gets in
the way of all of whites pieces by all
of the pieces I mean this bishop in this
rook in particular these two pieces
cannot really influence the Kings side
with this pawn in the way it's true why
could still open things up with captures
or push for example of captures but now
it is actually black who's benefiting
the most perhaps will insert this
movement yet again and then play Knight
takes f5 and we are really looking at
some critical squares here and we are
the ones who have taken over on on this
side of the board in fact and the e-file
is going to be what black looks to use
in this game so I like to move f5 here
in particular if white decides to play
things a little bit more slowly and in
fact we could even consider moves like
f5 on this turn as well although e5 is
likely White's response and then still
just playing for this similar stuff
looking for these kinds of squares in
the center and long term we still have
this plan of b6 a 6 and b5 this is kind
of what we can fall back on after we
solidify things on the Kings side just a
little bit yet someone else mentions a
tactic a6 does in fact actually just
hang Knight b6 but even in the general
sense for example with this Queen on d8
still obviously you can't play it here
but a5 is going to be a good response to
to a6 in in most positions but okay so
in the game though white did not adopt
this slower approach with b3 if he did I
once again was going to recommend a move
like f5 to just kind of challenge the
center instead though Queen e1 was
played Bishop takes c4 D takes e4 and
now d3 and this is just going to be a
really pleasant position for for black
here
if white tried c3 perhaps it would have
been a little bit of a better attempt
moves like Knight a5 though are going to
come onto the board and these things are
all kind of going to be hanging these
squares in these pawns
are gonna have a tough time surviving
instead though C takes D three years
played queen takes D three and now black
is simply much better
'if I've was played Knight f5 and black
is firmly control of all the key squares
in the position rook a3 allows black to
capture c4 and this game ended pretty
routinely for black from here on out I
do believe I haven't analyzed the rest
of this game too much in depth because I
was more focused on the opening but yeah
it looks like things really did just go
blacks way up an extra pawn and then
trading down in this endgame and he ends
up simply winning with this beep on
excellent game from black now I know you
see names on your screen but we actually
diverted from the main game here this
was actually a game between Andrew
Gaussian and Dre F so those two players
playing this game and it all comes back
to this mover key bone this is where we
deviated I probably should have
mentioned first of all in the main game
we're gonna look at another move for
white which is the move b4 trying to
take control of c5 but to recap this
this last line that we looked at here
this is kind of the more traditional way
of playing Kings Indian types of
structures why it forces black to kind
of take the center with a move like d4
and then goes for these plans with f4
and black has these various options to
respond to them and which one is going
to be best just depends on the position
so let's recap here riki one and the
move d4 is what was played in this game
that's what I'm suggesting as well and
then the move a4 is nice for white to
gain control of this C 4 square c5 for
black now is starting to advance on the
queenside defending the center we see
94-96
attacking the center and defending the
center now rook back to F 1 preparing f4
and black decides to put this bishop on
e6 by first controlling Knight g5 and we
have Bishop e6 at 4 we have a few ways
to deal with f4 the main point is you
just cannot really allow the move f5 to
come on the board so move like Queen d7
would be perfectly fine I move like f5 I
think it's a little bit too weakening
this early on and I liked black's
response in the game he takes f4 forcing
to kind of make the decision of how he
wants to recapture G takes up for is the
best recapture for white in this case
and then moves like f5 become very very
reasonable really at any point in in the
future of this game now in the game
though Queen d7 stops f5 prepares the
move rook d8 and then black went in for
this move Bishop takes e4 pushing
through with d3
and activating the pieces so this is
just kind of one way than a game in the
Kings Indian structure can go of course
no game is gonna be exactly alike but
hopefully this is a good introduction to
those kinds of ideas now let's back up
to that move on move eight where we
first look at looked at this move rook
e1 and the main game I want to look at I
want to examine the move b4 so this is a
slightly different way of approaching
this Kings Indian structure with b4
white is attempting to gain control of
the c5 square we saw in the previous
game of course black plays c5 and is
always threatening things like c4 so b4
is an attempt to cut that off before it
ever gets started by taking control of
c5 so what should black do in response
I'm willing to bet you guys at home
might be able to figure this one out
actually the the main move for black
here and also the best move
what do you guys think
waiting on the chats waiting on the
chats ketchup how do we respond to this
move beef or so yeah they are with me
now
after some delay it is in fact this move
a five this is kind of the problem with
the move beef or you are simply not
fully prepared to commit to defending
this pawn if you play the move c3
well now the move a takes b4 and C takes
b4 it could come on the board and you
really have no way now to challenge the
d4 square and your pawn is still going
to come under some fire after the move
Knight a six and really it's it's not so
easy to keep this pawn handled of course
the move a3 isn't that with Knight takes
b4 so rather than that white almost
exclusively takes this pawn off on a5
and the point of all this for white was
to gain some slightly more rapid
development on the Queen side so he
gives up this b4 pawn for the a5 pawn
which seemingly is a very good trait for
black it activates the Queen put some
pressure on this a to pawn what does
white get in exchange well white can
play very very quickly with this move
Bishop b2 in the point now for white is
that after the main move d4 well after
Knight be free this move c3 is going to
come for white and after c3 white is
actually looking to break down this
entire structure for black not from the
base of the pawn chain was something
like f4 going after the e5 pawn but
instead from the head of the pawn chain
with something like c3 going after this
d4 pawn more directly so in the game
Queen c7 was played and white wasted no
time immediately playing this move c3 so
what should we do about c3 what can be
done there's a couple options here and
I'll let you guys at home try try and
work this one out what can you do about
this move c3
gonna give you just a second to think
about it and then I'm gonna start
talking before I actually see responses
because the delay just doesn't work out
with this this question-and-answer
format so take a second to think about
it still okay so of course hopefully the
two options you came up with at home are
the moves see five supporting the center
in this manner and the move D takes III
D takes T 3 is a really interesting
option for black to permanently change
the structure so C 5 is a fine move for
black blacks not really doing worse
after this the move C takes D 4 come on
the board and after C takes D four you
do just have some kind of open game on
the queenside here and I think black
might be slightly preferred in this type
of position well I can play a move like
a for taking some space moves like
Bishop a3 can come and the play is just
going to be on the Queen's side now for
example night BC six Queen c2 there
should be six for example sorry maybe
Bishop g4 for example but should be six
with me Knight g5 and then I move like
FB one and you know the play is just
kind of shifting to this side of the
board we're not too much has really been
proven in either sides favor but the
move I'm gonna recommend is actually
sorry the the other choice here that is
the move D takes c3 and I like this a
lot better for black because it's a
slightly more imbalanced position and
it's imbalanced I believe in blacks
favor so of course after Bishop takes c3
we have these two pawns against these
two pawns on the Queen side this is kind
of the structure and if you look very
very carefully you might notice that
these two pawns are connected and this
pawn is backwards and this pawn is
isolated and it's for that simple reason
that I really prefer the the black side
here and the move c5 was played in the
game and I think was correct c5 is going
to be followed now by b5 and black is
always going to be threatening moves
like c4 to create a passed pawn and
that's exactly how the rest of this game
went so this is once again really the
nature of the Kings Indian attack white
is going to throw something at your
Center and it's all about finding the
best way to respond to the position
in the moment you know this can be in a
few different ways depending on the
specifics of the position so in this
case D takes c3
ended up being the right call because
after D takes c3 white has this
permanent weakness in the structure and
you get to place a little bit more
freedom with your pawns so this turned
out to be a really nice position for
black in this game and he did in fact
end up winning and the game continued
with Knight FD 2 and now simply b5 is
taking away a lot of squares from the
white player Queen c2 is played in the
game now Knight a6 is getting developed
Ric FC 1 this should be six and the
black pieces all flow very naturally
into the game this Knight comes over to
c6 and you can really see the game is
now all about these two pawns and they
turn out to be more of a strength than a
weakness here taking away all these
squares from white and leaving these two
pawns on week half open files 93 in the
game and then black simply just broke
through with seafloor and now white went
in for some bad tactics and that ended
up quite simply just losing the game B
takes d4 B takes e4 and then white goes
for 95 strange little Intermezzo trying
to hit the Queen but now black simply
takes on b3 and it's challenging whites
Queen as well the night takes c7 in the
game B takes c2 and I takes a and now 94
was the clever move from shepper enough
here simply guarding this pawn on c2
Knight b6 is an attempt to save the
night but now Rick p8 hits the knight
again and this Knight is looking a
little bit stuck 92 check is coming and
there's no way to really stop all the
threats Bishop a5 was tried in the game
and now Bishop h6 is simply attacking
this rook Bishop f1 and the rest is kind
of history here in knight c6 and takes
and black easily won this game up a full
night's up a full night perhaps not as
easily as he should have won it but he
did end up winning it with this extra
night so it was a really impressive game
from Ivan schipper run off there
hopefully I'm not saying that too
horribly wrong and it just goes to show
another game in the Kings Indian attack
the various ways that white can
challenge your strong
Center in the various ways you can
respond to that okay hopefully you have
a good feel for that kind of position
the King's Indian structures are some of
the most complex and all of chests in my
opinion so it's it's tough to give you a
full full feel of the position in just
one lecture here but hopefully it's a
good introduction and it gives you some
idea of the options for black in that
type of position now I wanted to move on
to the next slide line in the caro-kann
and this time I'm going to be talking
about the pseudo panel attack so earlier
in the this little series of Kara
lectures I've been doing of course went
over the pan off attack which starts
with you know one e4 c6 d4 d5 takes
takes and then the move c4 this is the
main move order for the panel of attack
now the pseudo pan of attack is like the
pan of attack except pseudo so instead
of going for d4 directly immediately
exchanging off with a takes d5 in this
case white is going to go for the
slightly trickier move of c4 and with
this move order white delays playing the
move d4 and sometimes he doesn't do it
for any good reason sometimes white just
plays d4 anyways pretty quickly but
sometimes white goes for some real
sidelines where you delay playing d4 for
a while and you try to use the extra
tempo with white to do something useful
now what I'm going to recommend here is
simply just playing the move d5 as
normal no need to deviate from the
status quo on this one and the main
moves here for white are simply to
capture this pawn twice of course in
this position white can simply play d4
and we are just perfectly back in our
main line of the pan of attack but C
takes d5 much more common here and now
the move Knight f6 is what I'm going to
recommend for black you can play the
move Queen takes d5 but you're just
walking in tonight's e3 kind of for no
reason so I recommend the move Knight f6
just trying to regain this pawn in the
most natural way possible and now once
again it is possible to transpose and
the main main stuff in the pan off so
I'm talking Knight c3 now black could
capture on d5 here and at any moment now
white can play d4 and you were just back
in the main line of the pan off instead
though white could play move like Knight
f3
now knight c6 end of d4 here we just
really fully have transposed and if
Bishop b5 well then white has kind of
committed to a sub-optimal square for
the bishop so I'm just gonna recommend
the movie 6 and now it's true that we
didn't get our Bishop out to g4 before
playing a6 but white put his Bishop on
this slightly silly square on b5 when it
would much rather be behind a d4 pawn
sitting on d3 so both sides have kind of
gained something and left something
behind and now I'm not gonna spend too
much time analyzing these kind of lines
cuz you just get a fairly standard
position with an isolated Queens pawn
and those are positions for for another
lecture in fact I've taught lectures on
isolated Queens pawn queen pawns before
so if you're confused on those go watch
another lecture in the main line I want
to go over today though of course I'm
going over the Charis sidelines so I
want to go over the ones that don't
really transpose quite so easily so the
move I wanted to look at in the main
variation is this move Queen a4 check
this is a move aimed at actually making
it a little bit more awkward for black
to regain his pawn here on d5 with Queen
a4 check you're using this pawn as white
to prevent the knight from coming to c6
and you're forcing black to make some
slightly awkward decisions the line I'm
gonna recommend is the main one with
Knight bd7 and the point now for white
is afternoon 8c3
obviously this pawn is not yet
capturable so I asked you now if you at
home can come up with a way to develop
the black pieces here how can you
develop the black pieces with the
super-annoying pawn sitting on d5 what
can you do what can you guys at home
figure out for black
I'll give you just a moment to think
about it I'm gonna start explaining it
anyways as I said it's a bit silly to
wait the full time for the delay okay so
hopefully you came up with some options
of course the movie six is going to be
just totally fatal you can't really play
this and get your Bishop out like this
you're actually just giving up a full
pawn and totally destroying your
structure in the center so there are a
couple options for black I'm going to
recommend the line with g6 and with g6
you are simply preparing to develop your
Bishop out to g7 and Castle this way you
leave this pawn on d5 and it seems like
it's a really really annoying pawn but
in fact you can kind of develop around
it and this pawn on d5 is not going to
remain there permanently it's very
difficult to defend with the white
pieces and you'll regain it at a later
date I also wanted to mention the move a
six no move a six is also a totally
playable line if Knight f3 you're simply
going to go back for more and g6 stuff
or even go for immediate ideas here on
the Queen side with Bishop b7 follow so
this is also a pretty fine way of
playing the move b6 was suggested I
don't know how I feel about the move b6
I don't feel good I think you're just
weakening these light squares a little
bit too much I think I think it's much
better to go for the moves a 6 and b5
then the structure with a 7 and b6
when all of these light squares just
start to feel a little bit too tender
for my liking so the main move though g6
is what I recommend for black why it's
going to continue development in one way
or another well I can also just play the
move d4 but in classic the pseudo payoff
style for some reason white decides he
doesn't want to play this move
so Bishop g7 Bishop c4 and King side
castles is pretty standard stuff here
pretty standard stuff now white usually
actually goes from the move d3 instead
of d4 here and the reason is he just
wants this nice open diagonal
perhaps her bishop on e3 he wants to
support this bishop on c4 and he wants
to control the e4 square as well so the
pawn on d3 achieves these things whereas
the pawn on d4 might end up just being a
little bit of a tart
on this diagonal for this bishop so now
black is going to continue very
naturally with the move a six like I
said just guarding some of these light
squares around the camp now rather than
walk into things like b5 I don't know if
it would work immediately here for
example if I move like Bishop III I
don't think you can play b5 just yet but
rather than ever allow a fork to happen
Queen a3 is by far the main move also
putting some pressure on e7 and keeping
in mind some d6 ideas so this is the
main move for white and now black is
simply gonna play b6 and develop the
bishop out here so this is how you kind
of develop around this d5 pawn you just
being cut out both bishops and then life
is perfectly fine now why it's going to
find the castle black and play Bishop e7
and start targeting this pawn and now
moves like rook e1 are gonna come on the
board well it's gonna put a little bit
of pressure on e7 no worries though just
rook e8 and the main move here is
actually Knight g5 preparing to reroute
over to e4 rook c8 was played in the
game and this is totally fine pretty
comfortable actually for the black
player now white could try to
desperately hold on to e5 with a or d5
rather with a move like Bishop e3 but
now black can play moves like Knight e5
and it's becoming really really
impossible actually to hold on to all of
these pawns in the center I don't think
there's really a move here for white
that holds on to everything so much more
common and what was played in this game
is actually just the move d6 d6 or
removing this pawn from all these
threats of capture and challenging a7
once again so of course though black is
not so naive as to take this pawn and a
lot Bishop takes f7 instead the movie
six comes on the board stunting this
diagonal and you just leave this d6 pawn
here and you're kind of just gonna sweep
it up at a later date this pawn is way
too far up the board in order to be
defensible and so the idea for black is
you've already developed your pieces
around this d5 pawn you're in no rush to
really
take it back and your position is it's
just gonna be totally fine here so II
six Bishop f4 was played in the game now
black finally expands with the move b5
Bishop drops back to b3 and the move
Knight c5 comes on the board so you see
all of the black pieces really just have
natural developed squares this Knight
coming to d5 at a later date this nice
Knight on c5 hitting some weaknesses and
that's really all you can ask for from
the opening here so blacks pieces
natural squares serving purposes active
squares and black is just going to look
to regain the d6 palm later so Rick a d1
played in the game and then black
continue with Knight h5 hitting this
Bishop opening up this Bishop and
finally coming to collect Bishop e3 was
played hitting the knight on c5 so
Knight takes b3 it takes b3 and then
black went for this move f5 taking away
some nice hops for these horsies so no
hops for the horsies f5 instead takes
away the e4 square Knight age 3 was
played and then Bishop f8 and it's like
I said this pawn just too far up the
board at some point it's going to fall
into blacks clutches so Bishop c5 tries
to hold on
but now black actually plays a really
nice move here so I'll let you guys at
home try and find a Black's next move to
secure an advantage see if you can find
it
Black's next move secures a solid
advantage
okay hopefully you guys at home found it
again I'm not going to totally wait the
full delay the move of course is rook
takes c5 sacrificing the exchange and
then you are finally winning this pawn
back if you want to play a little bit
more conservatively I suppose you
couldn't really play the move rook c6
well I guess you could actually could
just play rook c6 and take this guy back
I was worried about d7 for a second but
these tactics don't amount to anything
so that game I continued t7 takes takes
takes and and black is doing totally
fine here as well but I like blacks move
rook takes c5 sacrificing the exchange
getting the bishop pair getting the pawn
back and these open diagonals are just
gonna be devastating devastating for
black so it looks like a few people got
it Gavin Paul I'm a doc gamer fat cheese
stick it's a good username fat cheese
stick found the answer the move of
course is rook takes c5 giving up the
exchange and now these are just
devastating bishops on some of the
longest diagonals on the board and in
this game
white ended up simply crumbling let's
take a look at how it happened Queen e3
Queen c7 g3 tries to stunt these bishops
now Queen c6 switches diagonals g3
strengthens the dark squares but weakens
the light squares and it's very apparent
here now f3 for white tries to hold
everything together and in the game
black simply went in for Queen takes f3
and I threw away some of the advantage a
little bit better would be to play the
move e5 just taking more control over
the position bringing this Knight back
to f6 and being no rush really to to
continue playing for example the game
can continue knight or e5 the move d4
takes advantage of this pin Knight f6
unpinned and then a move like I don't
know even Queen f2 but already things
are kind of falling apart you can
reroute this Bishop even to b6 and this
King is just not gonna have I'm not
gonna have a safe home and instead the
Queen takes f3 was fine for black in the
game takes takes rook d2 and then black
managed to coordinate with the bishops
against the rook and ended up winning
this game let me see it takes and it
takes and then with the better pawn
structure black ended up pushing to f4
got this rook and Knight active and wait
did he even win this game I don't even
remember looks like he didn't win this
game looks like it was a draw but black
had a much better position so good
enough for a draw in this case probably
should have been good enough for more if
you followed all those blast moves there
congratulations to you you have
superhuman speed but the point is black
had a very very crushing advantage
earlier on in this game I suppose that's
my fault for not watching to the end of
the game but it doesn't matter
it's an openings class not an endgame
class once again the point of this
opening for white is to get a slightly
annoying pawn on d5 and make it
difficult for black to recapture however
fortunately for black you can always
develop around this pawn with these
kinds of ideas and the pawn will prove
to be overextended in good time as
always in the opening just look for good
pieces or good squares to put your
pieces on good ways to improve your
pieces and then you should be doing just
fine so this of course is the pseudo pan
off attack the pan off normally coming
after d4 the pseudo pan off coming after
c4 and in most lines against most
players you're just gonna transpose into
a normal pan off with d4 at some moment
but if white wants to stick to his guns
and prove that the pseudo pan off is a
legitimate opening then he will try to
keep this pawn on d5 and once again you
just develop the pieces around this pawn
okay with the last 15 minutes I want you
to introduce one of my favorite side
lines against the caro-kann it's my
favorite for black I don't play it with
white because it's bad it does though
have by far the best name of any of the
caret con variations and actually just
give me one second here well I type in
the players names PG n Tex somehow I
miss this one we have of course magnus
carlsen against wesley so and after all
it must be a good opening if magnus
carlsen is playing again playing it
against wesley so right
so so there you go point proven it's a
great line that that's a lie by the way
bangles plays all kinds of terrible
openings all the time just because he
likes playing chess so II for c6
and then the Shocker on move to the move
that no one saw coming it is of course
the move
ready ready everyone Bishop to c4 now
for those of you at home who have not
seen this before Bishop c4 is known as
the hillbilly attack don't ask me why
it's known as the hillbilly attack
likely I don't know someone just thought
it was funny I was trying to come up
with some analogy to actual Hillbillies
but I just couldn't do it I just
couldn't do it so fish up c4 now this
move does not make a ton of sense I'm
going to be 100% honest with you
white develops this Bishop out to c4 and
of course it just walks right into
blacks next move the move d5 and this is
simply gaining time on the bishop for
black so with this this line the bishop
simply has to retreat and now from here
black is simply going to have a pretty
distinct advantage I think you can guess
the next move
the main next move is actually going to
be D takes e4 D takes e4 is going to be
good enough for black and sorry just
switched main variations here but in the
main game I wanted to look at black
actually played east six and this is the
game between magnus carlsen and wesley
so and ii 6 is more or less fine for
black but really there's no reason to
not take here on e4 so this is the line
I'm gonna recommend I wanted to quickly
show this line with East 6 just to show
you how things can start to go a little
bit wrong and the game Knight c3 was
played 9 f6 d3 and you add D takes e4
and Knight takes e4 Knight takes pawn
takes and the Queen takes d1 and King
takes d1 and now you really just end up
in a version of the endgame line that I
showed earlier in the stream with the
Kings Indian attack and Wesley so ended
up actually losing this game
despite being totally fine out of the
opening I do want to mention this was a
very very fast time control in fact I
think it was one of those chest columns
speed chess championships so we won't go
into this one in too much depth the main
line I want to look at now is D takes e4
so this is by far the best move for
black you you simply take the the free
pawn here and then you're up a pawn and
that's that's the story of the hillbilly
attack white just loses upon so the main
move now is the move that Carlson played
in the game it is the move Queen h5 okay
so queen aged 5 here and let me just do
this and queen h5 of course makes a
threat it makes the threat be careful be
careful
don't play the move e5 the movie 5 worst
move in the position I found it there's
no move worse than a 5 you quote me on
that but the movie 6 is is gonna be
totally fine for black here and black
once again is up upon so don't get
checkmated now the move Knight c3
threatens to take your pawn back so of
course you should develop with tempo hit
the Queen defend the pawn perfectly fine
Korean age 4 was played in the game and
black just plays the move Knight BD 7
now if white really wants to like and
recapture this pawn here on e4 but the
fact is it's just going to be a little
bit silly for white to play like this
White has just lost a ton of tempi black
has made no weaknesses and black has
some pretty free development now with
with Bishop d6 you know this Queen
traveling all across the board is not
the ideal way to play the opening for
white so keeping in line with the
opening Magnus continued with the move
f3 offering up another pawn in exchange
for more development now if you really
want to be brave you can play the movie
takes f3 and after Knight takes f3 White
gets one free developing move in
exchange for a pawn which is not worth
it black is much better here but I like
the move played in the game and that
move is Knight c5 it guards the e4
square and just threatens to to take off
this this Bishop on b3 Magnus in the
game captured on e4
another move Knight f takes e4 is the
nice tactical justification for blacks
last move you cannot take back here as
the Queen hangs and if Queen takes d8
which was played in the game simply King
takes d8 Knight takes e4 and Knight
takes e4 and now we see that White's
pressing advantage from the first move
you know the the huge gain and
development that he got with Queen h5
with tempo has has really dissipated
into an endgame down upon now if your
name is magnus carlsen you can in fact
play like this at the world blitz
Championships against in this case this
line was against thomashefsky at the
2015 world blitz and if your name is
magnus carlsen you can play like this
and still win the game he he managed to
win this position with white here which
is a truly impressive feat but if your
name is not magnus carlsen likely you
were just very very sad about your
opening choice because there is no
downside for black here black is simply
up upon up upon for nothing so the the
huge hillbilly attack has not has not
really worked out here for white there's
question in the chat in hillbilly attack
I always see white taking with pawn on
move three that's that's interesting
because this is really not the main move
I guess it's playable as well Bishop b3
but the ideas are all going to be the
same
the downside for white now is that you
don't have this queen h5 stuff which
Magnus went for it in his game the
upside is you're not totally down a pawn
but also what's what's the upside here
I'm not seeing the upside black just
develops as a strong pawn on d5 and you
have a a slightly nonsensical bishop on
b3 in fact if I'm honest with you I
expect later in the game white is going
to be playing to move c3 and try to
bring this Bishop back to c2 so really
no purpose in playing the hillbilly
attack if this is going to be the way
you play it
because blacks just gonna end up with a
pawn on d5 and it's it's going to be a
strong point for
black and really nothing doing now for
for white but okay who wants to see
Wesley so lose a really embarrassing
game I know I do so okay and then Wesley
slows game he played a six Magnus
continuing out with Knight c3 Knight f6
d3 and like we like I said earlier they
got into this end game so of course
Wesley not accepting the free pawn on e4
perhaps a bit of a misstep free pawns
are good 97 was played in the game which
is a perfectly fine move than c3 now
Knight c5 also a great move getting this
knight on a nice square
well let's challenge where it challenges
both of these pieces then Bishop c2 have
I looked at to Knight c3 three Queen f3
I've not looked at that variation
actually I think I've faced that
variation maybe once or twice in in my
entire chest career but I'll give it a
brief mention after we see Wesley so
lose Knight f3 d6 Bishop e3 Bishop a6
and the fact is white just simply got a
little bit more space here with moves
like b4 in b takes a5 now can you see
one bishop a through check came up to d2
h d8 and wesley so was doing just fine
until all of a sudden he wasn't white
takes off this pawn on 85 and then
doesn't really get it back and Wesley so
now down to pawns ended up losing this
game to Magnus Carlsen in the hillbilly
attack really unfortunate stuff for
Wesley so ok there was a question of a
sideline that I had totally forgotten
about cuz who plays like this there is
this move Queen f3 here too to look out
for and it's another one of those
variations where white is just going a
little bit crazy the move D takes e4
it's still going to be the move I
recommend Knight takes e4 now recaptures
this pawn and you can just simply
develop your pieces now Knight d7 Knight
f6 is going to come if the move Bishop
c4 happens
still just Knight f6 it's totally
totally fine against all these weird
variations black more or less plays the
same way you take on e4 you develop your
pieces you're better that's that's what
happens
against side blends in the caro-kann I
guess this lecture could have been a
minute long where I said why it's gonna
play some garbage you develop your
pieces take on e4 and then then you're
totally fine but that's honestly the
truth for these sidelines
so okay do you take C 492 c4 and then
looking here the main line is as with d4
but you just develop your pieces and
once again you're gonna be totally fine
even just a six here is simple enough
you develop you trade you get your
pieces out and then life is good okay
any final questions before before I
leave here the fantasy variation is is a
comment I'm seeing in the chat
in fact I've done so many of these
CARICOM lectures now I totally forgot I
hadn't covered the fantasy yet so stay
tuned next week likely it'll be a
fantasy variation lecture two to
actually complete the caro-kann here I
think the fantasy is worthy of more than
just an honorable mention in the
sidelines lecture so we'll give the
fantasy its its own lecture because that
it is a rather tricky opening that
deserves a little bit more more comments
so stay tuned for next time
we want to see the Grand Prix the Grand
Prix doesn't really work against the
caro-kann doesn't really work okay is
the last thing I'll go over and then I
think I'm gonna call it here if you are
watching live be sure to head over to
the twitch channel after this when I
have an exciting tactical challenge for
you on this tactics time if white wants
to play like this the fact is you're
just gonna get into some caro-kann
advanced positions so I would recommend
checking out that lecture in fact I
think I might even mention this line in
that lecture the difference is of course
white has committed to this move at four
when white didn't really need to commit
to this move at four so after the move
like d4 the plans are going to be all
the same as the advance variation you
play c5 you develop these pieces Queen
b6 is a common idea and you just follow
those same same plans from the advance
caro-kann only difference is it spawns
already on f4 is it a good thing maybe
not maybe not for white actually okay
should you change French defense for
caro-kann yes next question alright I
think that's just about going to do it
for us here thank you so much for
joining me on this lecture on some
sidelines against the caro-kann and how
you should face them my name is Caleb
Denby and stay tuned for more chess
openings explained next week and a
tactics time lecture on twitch if you're
watching live thank you very much for
joining me and I will see you next time
[Music]
you
[Music]